Let's talk about the polling.
We all must be cautious, careful and diligent
in our participation in this election.
We all must vote.
We almost get people to vote.
But as a brief interlude to our discussion
of the last 24 hours, polling has completely
imploded this week for Donald Trump.
I'm going to go through with you all of the
new polling now that we are just 25, 26 days
from the election.
And it is a variable, veritable disaster for
Donald Trump.
If these numbers are even remotely accurate
and if voter suppression and dirty tricks
don't end up being how Trump claws his way
back up, this could be really bad for Trump.
If, if, if, if we vote and remember, this
polling is all post first debate and it is
post Trump getting Corona virus and pulling
his Covanta stunt on the White House portico.
So far as nationally, Joe Biden is plus nine.
In a new poll.
Plus 10 in a new poll.
And shockingly.
Plus twelve in a new Rasmussen poll, typically
one of the most right wing polls that we have.
If you look overall at recent national polls,
this now pushes Joe Biden's advantage to an
average of nine point four points over Donald
Trump.
As you can see in the trend lines, it is not
going in the right direction for Trump.
The recent reversal with a Trump decline and
Biden ascension started on September 29.
That's where we've seen this drop for Trump
starts September 29.
Now, let's not go crazy.
We still have almost four weeks to go.
If we look at Trump versus Hillary 26 days
out from the election back in 2016, remember
in 2016, the election was on November eight.
So if we go back 26 days from the 2016 election,
Hillary's lead with six point seven.
So, yes, Joe Biden's lead today is bigger
than Hillary's four years ago.
But Hillary was also climbing at this point
in 2016.
And Biden's lead now is only 40 percent bigger
than Hillary's was.
You might remember I told you a few days ago.
Biden's lead today is 140 percent bigger than
Hillary's was at this point four years ago.
Biden's lead is growing, but Hillary's was
growing even more quickly at this point in
time.
So let's just understand that not become complacent.
Now, let's look at some state polls.
And remember, we have an electoral college
system in this country where each state is
worth a certain number of electoral votes,
270 being the total you need to clinch the
presidency.
The latest state polls are very bad for Trump.
Yesterday, we had a new Marquette poll for
Wisconsin and Biden is plus five.
That's good for Biden, Ohio, according to
New York Times, Siena.
Biden is plus one.
If Biden wins Ohio, you can essentially say
goodbye to Donald Trump in Pennsylvania.
From Emerson, Biden is plus five.
But then we have a Quinnipiac poll which has
Biden up 13 in Pennsylvania, eleven in Florida,
which is just incredible.
And five in Iowa.
And then also notable yesterday, New York
Times Siena poll says Biden is up six in Nevada.
And even the poll out of West Virginia that
says Trump is up 18.
Remember that in 19, 20, not 19 in 2016.
Trump won West Virginia by 42.
If indeed, Trump wins West Virginia by only
18.
That would be a very small margin of victory
in one of the reddest states in the country.
So the debate clearly did not work well for
Donald Trump.
Having Corona virus, pulling his Corona ride
and Kobie to stunts have not helped him.
And now we will wait and see what the impact
of the vice presidential debate is, if any.
Let me know what you think it will be.
I'm on Twitter
at
David Pakman.